when people have first learned three
beat weaves forwards and backwards
weaves they tend to think of it as
something they're doing in front of them
in a wheel plane and that's reasonable
that's a sort of inevitable way to start
will open up more possibilities if
you're able to also think the weave as
something that's happening on wall plane
on either side of you and you get there
simply by learning to loosen up into the
gyration of the move so when you're
doing the we you found fish you for a
second they never to believe you're
turning back and forth you're gyrating
I'm gonna call it gyrating with the
movement so what you want to do is just
really day by day slowly slowly
learn to let your shoulders and your
whole body follow the crossing more and
more then it helps actually if you bring
your hands closer to your chest
eventually you can gyrate with the poi
enough that you're actually going right
into wall plane on either side if I look
this way I see wheel plane again but if
I look to you look away look to you on
either side of me I can have the
perspective of it being they won't plane
that's where I can do a lockout
I'll lock oh just minutes it open my
arms a little bit and let the point keep
going
I choose one play has to be closer to me
than the other one and this position
opens up a whole lot of points some of
them are advanced so for instance I
could do in Iraq of course I can do my
windows I can start to play with
isolations and pops there's a whole lot
of possibilities there and I can go into
all of my buzzsaw fountains my 4x4
fountains and whatnot you do your weave
first just notice it look at your
shoulders you're already gyrating back
and forth pull your hands in close to
your body
and just over time you're going to learn
the gyrate all the way so you're looking
from one wall playing to another the
move doesn't change it's really still
the same move once you've got that tore
you see a moment of wall playing and
back a moment of all playing in the back
learn to do a walkout once you've got
that that's where it all opens up so
take skeevers up days or weeks and takes
practice and that will prepare you for
turning your weaves into a part of a
dance
[Music]